Mm,
as an entrepreneur,
I'm such an advocate for everyone to
think like an entrepreneur,
whether you want to start your own
business or not.
It's incredibly helpful no matter what,
and so thinking like an entrepreneur
inside of organizations or if you are
starting your own business,
I always say,
I love to tell the people around me to
do this.
Close Your eyes and take a minute and
think about how you would be doing your
job if nobody showed you how to do it,
what surfaces?
Because if you think about it,
we're all on autopilot.
We're doing things the way either
someone else showed us how to do it or
we saw and learned from watching and I'm
real.
Change only happens when you do it
different than everybody else.
So all the time I put myself through
mental exercises where I'm like,
wait a minute.
I know everybody's been doing it this
way for a really long time,
but is that the best way?
And I just see what comes up.
I also come across ideas and inventions
by going throughout my day looking at
objects and saying,
now how could that be better?
And why did the person who first created
the,
the gum or the,
which gum to me is so fascinating as
someone who started a brand with $5,000,
had to get an idea out there that didn't
already exist.
The footless pantyhose.
I love to think about people who first
introduced things to society.
And I think about the guy who did gum.
I'm like,
you want to talk about like,
can you imagine?
I thought I had it tough.
This guy's walking around going,
you just chew it.
You just put this wad in your mouth and
like people will probably like.
And then what?
Don't swallow it.
You just chew it like that's a pretty
hard sell,
you know,
at first.
And I,
I think that gum had no flavor and it
when it first came out,
so that's even crazier to me.
But everything from the pencil to the
fork to the chair,
we sit in to the car that we drive.
Somebody originally had the thought and
brought it forward to society.
So get off autopilot,
look at everything,
every object in your life,
the way that you do things.
You know,
when you get up and brush your teeth,
is there a better way to brush your
teeth?
Is it the right way to be doing it?
Um,
and see what comes.
So I started spanx with $5,000 in
savings from selling fax machines door
to door in clearwater,
Florida for seven years.
And I started it out of the back of my
apartment.
I had never taken a business class.
I'd never worked in fashion or retail,
but I was determined to make this one
particular undergarment for myself and
women that filled a much needed void and
fashion.
And it was the most challenging the
first two years to get it made because
no one took me seriously.
I heard the word no for two solid years.
I actually was calling all the hosiery
manufacturing plants and I ended up
taking a week off of work and drove
around North Carolina in person begging
these people to help make my prototype
and my idea.
And so there were many,
many times in those first two years when
I wrote my own patent.
I went to Barnes and noble and bought a
book on patents.
And trademarks,
you know,
I created the packaging on my friend's
computer after work.
Um,
you know,
I thought of the name spanx sitting in
traffic in Atlanta and went home and
trademarked it with my credit card for
$150.
But all of this time I was doing it.
I wasn't sharing it with anybody.
None of my friends or family knew what
my idea was.
And that was really important to my
journey because I didn't want to share
the idea just for validation because I
wanted to make sure that I spent any
time I had pursuing it instead of
defending it and explaining it.
And I think so often,
so many times people have an amazing
idea.
I mean,
you have a million dollar or billion
dollar idea in your life and the first
thing you want to do is turn to your
right or left at work until a coworker
tell your friends,
tell your husband,
your wife and out of love and concern,
you get a lot of feedback that stops
that idea right in its moment that it
happened.
And,
um,
but for me,
because I wasn't using a support system
on those times that I had doubt,
I ended up really,
I listened to a lot of inspirational and
motivational lectures.
And I would second guess myself.
I put those tapes in,
I drive around,
I'd have to give myself pep talks.
I mean,
it was a real back and forth for me to,
um,
keep believing in myself when no one
else was.